there's reason for hope  um and i am encouraged it's obviously  extremely sensitive and after all that  she's been through and her family have  been through i think all of us need to  just allow the process to complete if  it's possible to do so we all  desperately want her  to be free  but it's a very sensitive stage and at  this stage i think we need to just  let the process continue and hope  for the best what do you think the  government should be doing should they  be doing anything more at this stage  well at this stage i think  um there are proceedings in place um  there are reasons to be hopeful  but i don't think any of us should  say or do anything that might jeopardize  what i hope is good process